notre invité politique ce matin c'est
alexis corbière bonjour alexis corbière
je vous remercie beaucoup de députés la
france insoumise de seine-saint-denis on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale et florent bus on
va nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
il est journaliste à la république du
centre on va commencer évidemment par
cette crise sanitaire et cette
intervention des manuels macron que vous
l'avez que vous avez suivi avec
attention on n'en doute pas est ce que
pour vous c'est le bon calendrier la
bonne méthode
les bonnes mesures bon alors je dirais
vous savez qu'on a été très critique sur
beaucoup de choses mais cette fois ci il
ya une sortie progressive
ce qui n'était pas le cas la première
fois peut-être avons-nous été entendu
mais c'est comme ça qu'il faut on peut
faire d'alpha n'y a pas eu de
planification du jour au lendemain
c'était un peu arrêté bon donc il ya des
mesures qui sont annoncées mais
peut-être sur la forme mais c'est pas
secondaire doit vous et bon non pas que
je me sente au dessus des citoyens mais
enfin je suis parlementaire je découvre
les choses qui sont annoncés par le
présent avis que j'imagine pour les
sénateurs c'est pareil c'est à dire que
mon acte le fait qu'un homme seul décide
et nous annonce à la télévision la
manière dont les choses vont s'organiser
moi je suis pas pour banaliser oui
d'accord mais enfin admettez que on
était tous suspendus à savoir ce qu'il
allait annoncer
moi je n'aime pas cette banalisation de
l'hyper personnalisation du pouvoir nous
sommes une démocratie du moins il faut
se continuer à le faire s'il faut il ya
une culture politique m du collectif il
eût été bon que ce soient débattues
collectivement dans différentes
instances parlementaires sénatoriales et
ces ados bref le monarque a parlé il
annonce que des choses des mesures vont
être prises et encore je pense bon des
difficultés évidemment je pense
notamment tout ce qui est dans la
restauration il ya des aides à apporter
à mon avis pour aller la restauration
c'est dz séparés ou rouvrir avant noël
ça vous avait fait une croix dessus
non mais ça me semble moi j'écoute quand
même les scientifiques ça me semble
effectivement on va pas la circulation
du virus il faut le stopper
par contre je pense qu'il faut mettre en
place des mesures de partager envie de
dire
2 parce que ce qui s'est passé certains
secteurs professionnels ont été durement
touchés évidemment par covin mais
certains en ont profité il ya des
profiteurs de crise
je vais citer un grand groupe
emblématique amazon a réalisé tout de
même des profits significatifs et je
crois que ça doit être l'occasion de
considérer qu'une entreprise qui fait un
chiffre d'affaires de près de 5,9
milliards en france et qui paye si peu
d'impôts 400 millions doit être
sollicité payer ses impôts en france il
faut imaginer pourquoi pas une taxe
amazon pour que tous aient surprofits
soit plus mis au service du collectif et
afin que les tpe pme qui ont rudement
souffert de cette crise soient aidés en
plus de l'attaqué il réfléchit depuis
depuis des années nous on a proposé
aussi cette taxe amazon qui fait que sur
ces groupes qui font des profits
notamment dans cette distribution à
distance ils soient sollicités pour en
politique c'est particulière pour les
profits réalisés pendant la crise et
anita vous innovez ppp en particulier
qui touche ses ventes en ligne qui ont
augmenté quand vous avez amazon qui va
ouvrir encore prochainement onze grands
entrepôts et que les surface d'entrepôt
ne sont pas taxés de la même manière que
des surfaces commerciales normales
ce n'est pas normal donc c'est le moment
si on veut imaginer le monde d'après
parce qu'on a besoin nos commerces de
proximité donc ce monde après il doit
être aussi celui où on évite qu'il y ait
des surprofits qu'ils soient réalisés
par ceux qui détruisent des emplois
je rappelle qu amazon quand il crée un
emploi ils ont détruit 1,9
d'accord ça détruit des emplois donc
attention on a tous besoin de notre
petit commerçant de quartier de notre
boulanger etc et il n'y a pas de raison
qu'il n'y ait pas des systèmes de mise
en commun
c'est ce que nous on propose notamment
donc voilà ça ça peut être un élément
après je rappelle mais comme une fois
les cheveux et vos auditeurs l'ont
compris que nous nous pensons que
l'hôpital public malmenés n'a pas été
suffisamment aidé qu'on n'a pas vraiment
augmenter le nombre de lui que nos
personnes à la suite adhéré ce tabou il
était à mobiliser avant même la triste
ducobu l'hôpital public faut le défendre
c'est notre patrimoine de notre santé
publique on s'est aperçu dans cette
crise qu'on l'avait fort malmenée et si
on a confiné c'est aussi parce que nos
capacités d'accueil d'encaissement si je
puis dire face aux malades étaient
réduites je le dis de manière générale
et en particulier comme une hutte
seine-saint-denis l'hôpital andré
grégoire chez moi à montreuil
franchement les capacités d'accueil sont
réduites
il doit payer encore une dette absurde
donc c'est l'occasion aussi de revoir
tout ça d'effacer les dettes de
l'hôpital public et notre système
hospitalier
et puis tout ce toutou ce plafonnement
tout pendant cet échelonnement de choses
dont je pourrais entrer dans les détails
dans le corps à l'école on va en dirhams
ans emmanuel macron qu annoncé un
élargissement du fonds de solidarité et
ce matin dans le journal les échos
elizabeth denham nice du travail qui dit
y aura une aide exceptionnelle pour les
précaires qui sont fortement touchées
par cette crise y compris ceux qui
alternait entre périodes de travail et
chômage qu'on appelle les permis temps
ça va concerner trois cent mille
personnes dont soixante dix mille jeunes
est ce que vous dites ça c'est bien le
gouvernement peut écouter ce
gouvernement moi je ne veut le juger que
sur pièce et concrètement parce que
c'est le gouvernement le roi d'un
discours orwelliens vous savez dit la
chose pour l'un vers saint pour
faciliter l'emploi faut faciliter non
mais je ne la connais pas dans le détail
ce que j'observe qu'ils sont faits
retoquer par amp et c'est tant mieux je
m'en félicite par le conseil d'état sur
leur réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
signifie concrètement que les aides
apportées aux gens qui étaient au
chômage
hal est réduite à la baisse voire quatre
à cinq fois moins à tel point que le
conseil d'état s'en est ému en disant ce
n'est pas possible
donc si vous voulez la gestion curité
non mais oui mais je veux dire donc je
ne les crois pas sur parole avec 6 et
des aides qui sont significatives oui
mais bien souvent le gouvernement quand
il annonce des choses faut aller
vérifier dans le détail parce que c'est
le roi je vous dis de des formules pour
défendre l'emploi faut faciliter
licenciement pour défendre à de
manifester faut le réduire
donc c'est ce que nous on a pleuré ce
discours orwelliens du célèbre roman
1984 ou un état dean inverse de ce qui
fait donc non ils n'aident pas les plus
défavorisés je les vues très
concrètement vous savez en seine saint
denis des aides notamment je parle de
mon département parce qu'on est
particulièrement touché par la crise le
taux de mortalité a été plus élevée et
séduit à plein de choses dans notre
système sanitaire qui est la plus en
difficulté à la surpopulation dans les
logements etc et les aides publiques ne
sont pas à la auteur on apporte on
approche des fêtes de fin d'année le
nombre d'associations je vais en citer
quelques unes dans les connais secours
populaire restos du coeur secours
catholique qui font un travail
formidable et qui tout quand on prend
contact avec elles nous disent que le
nombre de gens qui viennent les
solliciter son c'est du jamais vu des
gens effectivement qui sont des
catégories sociales qui mène de l'emploi
qui sont en grande difficulté et les
aides de l'état sont très très en deçà
de la main donc moi je vois mon
on était à une marée de pauvreté
vraiment nous sommes à près de 10
millions de gens qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté en france et a
augmenté de 1 million depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron je ne dis pas qu'il
est seul responsable mais sa politique
ne l'a pas réduit et là à côté de ça on
sait aussi que nous avons en france des
gens qui accumule des profits d'un
auteur qui n'a jamais été vu donc plus
que jamais et en raison de partir de la
crise la question de la solidarité du
partage des richesses des politiques
publiques de redistribution reste
pertinente en deçà mais reconnaissait
qu'il y en a quand même des airs d'un
bruno le maire parle d'un chiffre de 15
milliards par mois vous avez vu les
chiffres du déficit les chiffres de la
dette qui sont complètement hors des
clous de l'union européenne est ce que
vous dites oui mais est ce que vous
dites c'est bien c'est bien qu'on
s'affranchisse de ces règles de l'ue
nocéenne ça va donc nous avons fait
campagne là dessus un peu vous avez non
mais ce que je veux dire non mais oui
mais en période de crise ce que je veux
dire
pour essayer de prendre c'est que quand
nous menions campagne on nous disait
vous êtes fous c'est impossible
je pense que si à son nous avions eu des
politiques de relance publics notamment
de relance économique d'emprunt etc
on aurait pu notamment renforcer notre
service public éviter le choc parce que
c'est ça aussi le problème est dans la
crise ils sont obligés de sortir des
clous et de l'orthodoxie dont il disait
qu'il était inconcevable de remettre en
cause et j'en veux dire que puisque on a
fait ça en raison de la crise due qu'aux
vives pour contrer passé en raison de la
crise de la pauvreté des inégalités car
je rappelle sans minimiser la clé du coc
vide que 10 millions de pauvres selon la
conception que je me fais de mon pays de
ma patrie et donc du tout le monde par
deux républiques aujourd'hui mois pour
moi la république elle est sociale est
un pays qui banalise le fait que 10
millions de gens vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté c'est qu'ils ne voient pas
aussi une urgence et une crise donc
pourquoi ce qu'on a fait dans cette
crise ne le ferai pas face à une autre
crise la pauvreté
oui je pense qu'elle est un visibiliser
même et on va même en parler sur le
sujet sont de tout à l'heure de la place
de la république
c'est que c'est souvent la chasse aux
pauvres qu'ils organisaient bien sûr
qu'il ya des politiques sociales qui
sont menées 1 qui peut tempère la crise
mais oui effectivement on est dans une
situation que voulez-vous mais chasse
aux pauvres ça va loin vous dit c'est
quoi c'est le gouvernement qui fait le
shabeb foot et l'essentiel de ce qui
s'est passé place de la république c'est
de dire vous n'allez pas vous installer
au coeur de paris et nous montrer qui a
à peu près de 2000 bourg tous les soirs
qui dorment à la rue et auquel nous
n'avons pas d'autre solution que de
mettre un coup de pied au derrière en
leur disant vous étiez portes de saint
denis partez et les déplacer un peu
mon troupeau c'est l'activité pastorale
de la police à coups de matraque
poussez-vous de la l'histoire pendant là
on est en train de changer de sujet mon
avenir parlons-en si vous permettez
c'était des camps qui était porte de
saint denis ou porte d'aubervilliers qui
ont été chassés d'accord et puis
progressivement toute une série de
personnes plusieurs centaines 500 600
700 peut-être qui depuis une semaine
circulent parfois à paris vont dans des
parcs auxquels ils sont chassés et c est
au bout d'un moment vous avez une action
symbolique organisée par des
associations humanitaires pour que les
pouvoirs publics prennent le dossier en
charge qui disent on va aller se poser
place de la république pour que ça se
voit et qu'est ce qui se passe à ce
moment là les gens sont ressassés de
manière pratique en brut al il ya un
sujet là dessus mais avant même de
parler de la manière dont la police est
intervenue
ils ont été renvoyés vers quoi vers la
seine saint denis là où on les avait
chassés
il faut au delà des politiques publiques
d'accueil de capacités d'hébergement où
il fait froid là actuellement à
emmanuelle wargon là les ministres en
charge de ces questions on disait hier
soir que deux cent quarante cinq d'entre
eux ont été relogés sur les 300 qui
était place de la république le
gouvernement ne fait pas rire sécrétion
des deux places il manque des milliers
de places mais sur ces gens qui étaient
place de la république et non mais ils
sont 245 personnes en 48 heures finales
pourquoi alors j'ai je la prends mon
mais pourquoi il a fallu ces images
spectaculaires pour qu'on en arrive là
s'il ya 250 personnes 6 et des places
supplémentaires qui sont créés à la
bonne heure je ne peux que m'en
féliciter mais pourquoi il faut qu'on
arrive à un tel degré de violence pour
qu'au bout d'un moment
quelque part ça donne raison aux
associations et au delà du caractère
inacceptable et de l'est je pense d de
l'attitude brutale qui ont eu lieu donc
ça donne raison aux associations de
militer de s'engager de donner de la
visibilité à tous ces gens on en revient
ce musée au point de départ bon sang
mais on le sait tous qu'il ya des gens
qui dorment à la rue
ceux qui nous regardent sans vie
peut-être en province mais je leur
annonce qu'à paris de plus en plus de
gens dedans dehors à la rue et c'est
inquiétant et on ne peut pas libérer
la preuve vous êtes en train de me dire
que grâce à cette action de 150 places
supplémentaires ont été trouvés le monde
et ceux qui militent ceux qui s'engagent
même sous des formes comme en irak
d'action un peu spectaculaire de donner
à voir la pauvreté ils ont raison
revenons au sens du message pour cent
mais dans ce pays on est calme attaché à
certaines valeurs seul de l'a22 de la
solidarité pour son tranchant de la main
tendue vers celui qui est à la rue et
c'est ça qui était en jeu d'abord
à l'occasion de la place de la
république pour ma part moi je me sens
pas bien comme vous d'ailleurs je suis
persuadé même si on ne connaît pas que
vous n'êtes pas à l'aise quand vous
voyez des gens pauvres qui dorment par
terre vous ne tolérez pas surtout dans
un pays est dans une ville en
particulier où on s'est parfois il ya
des logements vides des bureaux vides
depuis des années que certains grands
groupes notamment possède des dix
immeubles entiers et depuis des années
tout ça n'est pas occupé mon sens
revenons aux messages de gens qui sont
même pas dans ma famille je pense à
jacques chirac à l'abbé pierre à
l'époque à bien passer la loi de
réquisition
on peut imaginer ça quand on a des
milliers de gens qui sont dans une
situation dramatique et après on
travaille à trouver des solutions
je compte jouable je vois bien tout ça
n'est pas simple cd vaste sujet qui sont
des vagues migratoires mais dont on nous
montre quelles sont les conséquences
aussi de politique économique de traité
de libre-échange qui ont fichu en l'air
des économies de dérèglement climatique
vous savez il ya l'université de
columbia qui nous disait que d'ici 2100
on va avoir un europe une augmentation
des migrants de près de 180 8 % en
raison des dérèglements climatiques qui
sont dues aux modèles économiques que
nous employons tous les sujets se
tiennent mais en attendant c'est pas le
monde avoir le coeur sec et de penser
que ça avec la matraque qu'on va régler
ces problèmes là et on va rester sur ce
qui s'est passé place de larry puisqu'on
y est j'ai encore une question après sur
ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron mais on y
reviendra plus tard on va écrire florent
buisson qui nous a rejoint journalistes
à la république du centre bonjour
florent et je dois revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé notamment avec les forces de
l'ordre alors dit ça oui absolument est
ce que vous comptez demandé une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
alors c'est les poussières leur depuis
le temps qu'on en demande des
commissions d enquête parlementaire
barney et la difficulté sans être trop
technique c'est que ces dix jours peu
nous on peut pas obtenir chaque fois on
est obligé de faire le show mais j'ai vu
que plusieurs groupes notamment
d'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
l'on évoqué ce serait une bonne chose
il ya un rapport de l'igpn
commandé par monsieur le ministre qui va
être rendue nous on a un regard critique
sur les gp dont on pense qu'en france il
serait temps qu'on voit pas tant de
modèles sur ce qui se passe en
grande-bretagne une instance plus
indépendante avec d'ailleurs des
universitaires des citoyens parce que là
le problème de la police il faut aussi
ses positions sur un surcoût taux jugé
bien sûr nous vénale pointe de l'igpn
c'est que c'est la police qui juge la
police et souvent nombre de choses
restent un peu ben moi j'avoue j'avoue
mais comme quoi je me suis totalement
trompé que au soir des événements de
république de ces tristes événements la
parole du ministre ils ont qu'il avait
été choqué par les images qui demandait
un rapport au préfet l'allemand je me
suis dit le préfet l'allemand bon va
être remercié parce que ça commence à
faire beaucoup
le traitement extrêmement violent du
monde et gilet jaune des manifestations
à paris l'utilisation abusive de drogues
qui sont toujours la démission du préfet
quand celle ci parce qu'à part un prêt
mais aussi de formation des policiers
aujourd'hui son ont affaire à la menace
terroriste de la république à la gestion
des deux camps de réfugiés à la gestion
au quotidien de la crise sanitaire
puisqu'ils doivent faire des contrôles
il ya toutes sortes de missions qui sont
très différentes est ce qu'aujourd'hui
ils sont assez formés pour remplir ses
missions
non mais façon les ont amenés à son
pseudo police le reconnaissait même les
policiers ne sont pas assez formés on
veut même le maniement des armes et les
journées d'août sont de plus en plus
réduits sans qu'on ne sont pas assez
formés on leur doit combien 2 millions
d'heures supplémentaires non payées ils
sont à bout il ya une situation de
dégradation de leurs conditions trail là
encore je le dis commune
seine-saint-denis mois à bagnols et j'ai
pas de commissaire de plein exercice
cevoli là à côté ou s'ils sont dans des
préfaces quand je travaille je discute
avec eux des voitures qui fonctionnent
pas toujours on leur en demande beaucoup
là aussi exemple deux commissariats de
seine-saint-denis dont on parle beaucoup
trente postes en moins en dix ans par
exemple et c'est donc le trail de
policier est un travail difficile
maintenant je trouve que il ya aussi la
police doit après entendre que c'est un
service public ce qu'il doit accepter
qu'ils aient un regard citoyen sur ce
qu'elle fait parce que ils font ça en
notre nom
et hier soir l'autre soir ce qui s'est
passé toute la chaîne de commandement
manifestement il ya eu des ordres du
moins j'espère qu'il ya eu des
hortillons c'est encore plus inquiétant
comme quoi la place devait être évacuée
de manière un peu brutale d'accord et ça
c'est plutôt de l'ordre a été donné à
bâle errements
résultat sans la responsabilité de les
mots sont forts quand même le préfet dit
évacués brutalement la plaine à évacuer
oui par tous les moyens si vous nous
dire d'où brutalement oui c'est à dire
que j'imagine que sur place comment ça
se passe c'est qu'il ya dû avoir en
rapport pour dire ils sont installés
dans les tentes
qu'est ce qu'on fait et quelqu'un a dû
dire vous le dégager d'accord il n'y a
pas eu ça c'est le préfet qui peut dire
cela j'espère parce que si c'est pas le
préfet qui dans la chaîne de
commandement prendre la décision c'est à
dire que rares assez rapidement
quelqu'un a dû lui dire sur place il ya
des associations
il ya même des élus de la ville de paris
il ya même des journalistes il ya des
gens qui sont dans les tentes tout ça
quand même emmené il ya une appréciation
politique jeudi politique parce qu'au
bout du bio ou alors si c'est pas le cas
ça veut dire que les gens pendant une
expression triviale sont en roue libre
c'est à dire que c'est l'appréciation
direct du fonctionnaire de police ty et
ça c'est pas bon moi je continue à être
pour ça que il ya des actes qui sont
inacceptables sur plan individuel
l'image du policier que fait un croc en
jambe
c'est intolérable c'est sa
responsabilité mais moi je ne veux pas
faire porter uniquement la
responsabilité ce qui s'est passé
uniquement sur le dos de ceux qui sont
sur le terrain parce que les policiers
ou non ils sont placés dans une
situation où leur demande des choses
contradictoires et en policier il
exécute les ordres si on lui dit vous
dégagez tout le monde il dégage tout le
monde et il le fait pas en distribuant
si on s'en rend même pas le prix
finalement moi non mais rien qui se
passe c'est comme mon problème avec le
préfet didier lallement on sait que
c'est pas uniquement la sphère de la
place de la république
c'est qu'on a eu des manifestations de
gilles et jean n'a jamais eu autant
deuil arraché on n'a jamais vu ça une
trentaine de on a eu une des mains
arrachées
on a eu des gens blessés on a eu de la
part du préfet d'ailleurs je trouve une
incapacité y compris quand les gens
étaient blessés de s'enquérir de leur
santé je pense à monsieur gérard
rodriguez je le dis parce que c'est un
homme que j'apprécie sur plan personnel
un gilet jeune homme pacifique éborgné
part entière de l bd
pas un mot de la préfecture pour
s'enquérir de sa santé et c'est donc
cette ce rapport aux mouvements sociaux
qui est quand même la marque de notre
pays mon sens j'espère qu'on découvre
pas qu'en france ça manifeste ça crie on
est comme ça hein comme dix autres les
gaulois que comment dirais-je emporter
où j'ai oublié l'expression exacte est
d'ailleurs pas que des gaulois forte
heureusement d'autres pays ses bras ses
deux buts mais compris ce que j'entends
dire et cette logique confrontation elle
avec les mouvements sociaux est un
changement de la doctrine de police moi
j'ai en mémoire c'est le mon année de
naissance mais en 1968 tout le monde
s'accordait à dire que le préfet qui
était monsieur maurice grimaud kidder
théo gaulliste a tout fait pour que
pourtant 68 c'était tendu que les forces
de l'ordre ne se confrontent le moins
possible aux manifestants et nous sommes
sortis du déclenchement et un mot pardon
ya pourtant eu des morts oui bien sûr on
change de chemise et sur la loi sécurité
globale avec vos flancs oui absolument
sûr le sénat va corriger le texte dit
philippe bas qu'est ce que vous attendez
de cette correction l'a écoutée on va
voir
on va voir moi je n'attends rien
actuellement vous parlez du doigt des
projets de sécurité notamment l'article
pourquoi vous l'appelez le texte
philippe bas parce qu au sénat philippe
bas qui dit kiki dit que le texte va
être corrigé pardon mais vous m'avez
trouble et j'ai tenté de me dire non
alors on va voir
excusez moi parce que du coup je ne sais
pas lui qui parte le drone est d'accord
donc ce texte de loi qui a été adoptée
mardi dernier en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
bon il ya nombre il ya 32 articles il ya
toute une série moi qui me pose problème
dont il faudrait parler on a parlé
notamment des prérogatives de la police
municipale - pour moi il ya quand même
un petit problème à la pricipale fin
c'est un travail intéressant mais je ne
suis pas pour qu'elle prenne qu'elle se
substitue de plus en plus à la police
nationale donc fallait pas élargir ses
pouvoirs moi non je ne leur ai pas fait
l'utilisation de drones attention le
drone peut être utile par certains
moments mais la société panoptique en
permanence
personnellement cela m'inquiète
l'utilisation des armes de service en
dehors des heures de service je dis
attention ça met en danger les policiers
eux mêmes taux de suicide important dans
la police on le sait très bien les armes
qui circulent augmente ex-bloc ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
sujets au delà de l'article 24 puis cet
article 24 pour moi l'article 24 c'est
une usine à gaz
c'est un mécanisme extrêmement complexe
qui va ramener justement à ce que le
fonctionnaire de police
souvent dans la tension l'adrénaline du
moment appréciera tout seul si les
images qui sont prises sont en train de
diffuser et peuvent lui porter atteinte
à son intégrité physique et
psychologique donc bien souvent le
policier va dire vous êtes en train de
me porter atteindre le gars va dire non
mais si mais oui bon bref donc des
images vont être bloqués alors le texte
lui est ambiguë ne bien sûr monsieur
darmanin dit c'est pas exactement ça
mais c'est pas bien donc faux moi je
suis pour retirer cet article de manière
générale j'ai voté contre la loi je vais
être honnête mais s'ils pouvaient alors
une rédaction plus clair qui empêchent
cette ambiguïté qui permettent de toutes
manières que ce droit citoyen de films
et l'intervention d'un fonctionnaire de
police puissent être maintenus
je rappelle parce que ça a été
l'argument répété mille fois qu'à
l'heure actuelle d'ores et déjà dans le
cadre de la loi
d'autant que copenhague nuno nul n'a le
droit de menacer quelqu'un a fortiori de
le menacer de mort et a fortiori si
c'est un fonctionnaire de police donc
l'idée qu'aujourd'hui on serait les
policiers sera livré en pâture sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui pour dire pas de
mesures supplémentaires pour protection
protéger
les polices des réseaux sociaux non je
ne le crois pas enfin je veux dire
l'alimentation actuelle suffit ah bah
oui bien sûr bien souvent le ministre a
rappelé des gens sont sanctionnés il ya
même un site
le ministre de l'intérieur a rappelé le
site il s'appelle copwatch et dia des
sites où il ya des insultes auprès des
policiers mais ce site a été d'ores et
déjà interdits est d'ores et déjà si
vous insultez et si vous menacez
quelqu'un de mort bon ben c'est interdit
et il ne faut pas le faire donc il ya
beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé là dedans et
on voit bien qu'en vérité c'est quand on
suit les 17 loi ne sert à rien c'est
aussi à quoi elle sert je vous le dis
notamment avisé ses journalistes comme
on irait indépendant que l'on voit
aujourd'hui qui font ce journalisme que
je vais appeler horizontale
je pense notamment à une monsieur rémy
buisine vous savez du site brut qui fait
un travail formidable des prises des
mâles qui a été violentée notamment
l'occasion de la manifestion de
république y en a d'autres comme ça
aujourd'hui
la police ne supporte plus ces
journalistes qui sont sur place qui
capte des images bon euh c'est juste que
c'est un prix des journalistes en fait
moi je crois que ça ouvre la possibilité
à ce que des policiers puissent empêcher
que des images soient prises pour que y
ait des précisément eu un regard citoyen
sur ce qu'ils font et pourtant comme l'a
dit le ministre darmanin les images
place de la république l'ont choqué
c'est bien la preuve qu'il faut des
images et c'est la liberté de la presse
qui en jeu le 10 normalement en
direction de votre profession vous avez
bien raison de vous êtes mobilisés
c'est pas un à côté de la démocratie la
liberté de la presse la liberté de la
presse et montrer les aspects positifs
d'intervention de police
mais c'est aussi la capacité de dire
comme tout service public qu'il ya des
choses que nous n'acceptons pas parce
que nous sommes attachés à une police
républicaine
un policier qui fait son travail doit
être fier son boulot et ils ne sont
majoritairement mais il faut aussi dire
il ya des moments bon sang pourquoi
autant de kerdel bd pourquoi ce système
de massage pourquoi cette brutalité
vis-à-vis de gens qui sont uniquement
dans une détresse sociale etc etc et
dernière question oui on va parler
peut-être deux pour finir sur ce sujet
là sur le travail des journalistes bail
de tri des journalistes à dessein
puisque par le passé votre parti à la
france insoumise avait refusé notamment
d'accréditer certains médias pour
couvrir des événements est ce que vous
comme le ministre darmanin finalement
vous triez les journalistes ou non non
non je sais pas quoi vous faites
référence d'ailleurs il faut pas mais à
l'admission quotidien les journalistes
du quotidien une époque n'avait plus le
droit entre
mais c'est arrivé une fois alors vous
avez vous évoqué la liberté de l'api
câble à tous peut-être mais nous la
défendons et nous sommes les premiers à
la défendent
est ce que vous évoquez est une émission
satirique une fois au cas nous avions
reproché à suite d'un événement nous ils
avaient dans leurs cartes de presse nos
noms mais eux n'ont en l'occurence mais
ce que nous avions pas accepter c'est
que après un événement que nous avions
fait il avait interrogé des militants de
chez nous il avait choisi sur leur
physique ce qui était gros qui avaient
des dents abîmées et c'est pour se
moquer un peu
nous on avait trouvé ça assez dégradants
et on leur avait dit six pour venir
comme ça faire ce genre d'émission de
voir on avait peu apprécié depuis j'ai
eu des émissions la preuve que ce que
vous dites et quotidien vous savez ceux
qui ont pris des images notamment lors
de la célèbre père un sens là donc ils
sont ils viennent ils sont venus parce
qu'on leur a dit de venir
bon après moi j'apprécie pas le style
ricanante quotidien mais ils ont totale
liberté de faire le faire leurs choses
et nous ne leur avons jamais interdit de
faire quoi que ce soit et merci beaucoup
mais je me sens fier d'être venu nous
voir ce matin on regarde la une de
florent la une de la république du
centre première vague de plans sociaux
c'est à la une de votre journal florent
merci beaucoup d'être venu merci à
l'éclaircie quito club des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires le soir en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et télévisions locales et les
ondes des radios avec nous aujourd'hui
benjamin elle est tirée du pont
inhomogène ion prendre avec vous
messieurs des 10 ans de la question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité
journée spéciale aujourd'hui sur notre
antenne la qpc permet à un justiciable
de saisir le conseil constitutionnel sur
la constitutionnalité d'une loi on verra
tout ça et on sent direct avec le
président du conseil constitutionnel
laurent fabius on parle également de la
réforme des procurations tout cas de
leur simplification ça a été annoncé
hier par le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin au sénat il vous sera
désormais plus facile d'établir une
procuration et ce dès les prochaines
élections
on verra tout ça on sera en duplex
depuis marseille avec guilhem rica vie
de la provence mais d'abord vous le
savez c'est lors de notre reportage en
régions toute la semaine nous suivons
des maires aujourd'hui direction berck
sur mer dans le pas de calais ou pour
faire face à la fermeture des petits
commerces le maire a mis en place des
aides pour les commerçants vous allez
[Musique]